- Well, I was going to
ask you about your kids.
But everybody always
asks about kids first.
How are you?
- Oh. I'm okay. I was so
happy to leave my house.
I was so happy to leave. Just
my room, and my other room,
and the kids. Where are you
going, mom? Where are you going?
- Away.
- Yeah.
- Far, far away. To Burbank.
- To Burbank. It's been
a lot though, especially
a mom that's just trapped home
with their kids, it's a lot.
- I'm trapped home with my
kids, I hide a lot, they
find me in the pantry,
they find me in my closet,
they find me eating and drinking,
- Yep.
- They find me, literally,
they can find me.
And I have quite a big
house, I'm not gonna lie.
- Yep.
- And they find me.
- They find you.
- Mhm.
- They sense it.
- The other day I was talking
to my girlfriend, and she was,
we were, I don't even know, just talking.
I was like behind a chair in my room,
like, in like, you know,
criss-cross freaking applesauce,
like, and I'm like, and they're like,
what are you doing?
And I'm like, I'm in my
own Mommy fort. So, anyway.
- All my kids do are, they make forts.
- Oh, we made a fort this morning.
Before we left for school.
- Oh it's every time.
The only reason why there's not is because
I threw a Neverland party
for my kids so there's like
teepees and stuff so they're
not like...but usually
every day is a fort. I'm like,
can we build something else?
Can we call it a castle?
Can we call it, you know,
something, a tree house?
- Can we call it anything else?
- Anything else.
- No but we have forts,
we have forts upstairs
and downstairs, we had a
fort in his bed last night.
And before I left, like, the
couch had been taken apart with
every type of pillow,
sheet, they like just go.
- Cushions are all over the floor.
- All over the floor.
- Like thanks, cause that's super clean.